part of the marvelization of Hollywood
is you have all these actors who have
become famous playing these characters
but they're not movie stars Captain
America is the star right Thor is the
star I mean I'm not the first person to
say that I think that's been said a
zillion times you know but it's like you
know it's the these franchise characters
that become become come a star you know
okay here's a better way to say it it's
like you know before even 2005 2009 or
something like that if an actor stars in
a movie that does as good as the the
Marvel movies to do well that that guy's
a new star they're an absolute star and
that means that people dig him or her
yeah and they like them and they want to
see them and stuff and then they you
know uh Sandra Bullock is in speed all
right and everyone like thought she was
amazing in it all right she was Charming
as hell everyone fell in love with her
and so you know even she does a couple
of uh mediocre movies after that yeah
well people want to see it because they
they were excited they want to see her
in something else and she's good in
those movies but that's not the case now
no we want to see that guy playing
Wolverine or whatever